muy confusas las noticias sobre el ya
confirmado doble asesinato del
periodista británico don phillips y de
bruno pereyra el indigenista brasileño
ambos desaparecidos desde el 5 de junio
en el corazón de la amazonía brasileña
el principal sospechoso el pescador
amarildo dacosta ha confesado hoy ante
la policía que habría participado en la
desaparición de los cuerpos pero los
detalles son muy confusos él dice que no
efectúa los disparos que hubo una
tercera persona pero no revela la
identidad también dice que junto a su
hermano descuartizó y enterró los
cuerpos pero no explica la razón por la
que él se involucró en eso tampoco está
claro el móvil del asesinato hoy la
policía que sigue las búsquedas fue al
lugar donde se supone que se habría
enterrado a los dos desaparecidos junto
a marc y ha ido y hace poco ha
comunicado que efectivamente se han
encontrado restos humanos el móvil
podría ser la lucha que bruno pereyra
hacía contra la pesca ilegal en las
reservas indígenas una pesca que no era
material que no era de eso vivencia sino
que era hecha con grandes barcos y que
dejaba muchos estragos en el medio
ambiente y también en el sustento de los
indígenas y polémica también porque el
presidente dijo ayer bolsonaro ha dicho
hoy públicamente que el periodista don
phillips no era muy querido en la región
porque hacía muchos reportajes en contra
de los garimpeiros de los buscadores de
oro no es la primera vez que se refiere
así a los desaparecidos hace unos días
llegó a decir que eran unos aventureros